for today's classic interview we're
going back to April of 2015 I had an
interview with a libertarian named John
Tammany and we couldn't even agree about
basic economics I love these
conversations with libertarians where
their worldview seems to be informed by
a totally farcical understanding of the
most basic economic concepts and I think
this is particularly relevant now
because with Donald Trump's tax plan we
are seeing the rehashing the
revitalization the Renaissance of
debunked supply-side
so-called free market economic ideals
and I think it's a nice tie-in with my
interview back in April of 2015 so let's
get into it I interviewed John Tammany
and we just couldn't seem to agree
really about anything let's take a look
I'm joined today by Forbes editor John
Tammany also author of the new book
popular economics with the Rolling
Stones Downton Abbey and LeBron James
can teach you about economics
you wrote the super interesting article
about your opposition to Marco Rubio's
tax plan Marco Rubio of course
Republican candidate in the 2016
Republican primaries I agreed with so
much of what you said which is
interesting because I don't agree with
much that's published in Town Hall
typically but I didn't necessarily agree
with some of the reasoning so let's
start at the beginning what is it about
Marco Rubio's tax plan that you don't
like well because it has nothing to do
with economic growth and in my view I'm
a libertarian but I've Republicans
aren't about growth to me they're about
nothing this is a tax plan that says the
government is we are going to subsidize
ongoing child birth so that we can
continue to pay for the ongoing growth
of government I don't see the growth
there I just see two guys trying to
subsidize bigger and bigger government
so your problem is that the plan from
Marco Rubio is is growing government I
mean if we were to say here's the
overarching disagreement you have is
that it's it's growing government well
it's that and then we're also talking
about a plan that basically uses the tax
code to socially engineer and these guys
Rubio and Lee bill them
as conservatives I don't see what's
conservative about government or using
the tax code to socially engineer
society so talk about that because this
is a part I'm glad you're mentioning
this because in the article you you
talked about I'm guessing what you mean
by penalizing the hard work of the
successful is that the top tax rate
would be reduced slightly but but not
enough for you right yeah no I
you're absolutely right I don't see why
Jeff Bezos who has created something
that allows me to order the world's
plenty with a mouse
I don't see why Michael Dell who has
made it possible for me to own a
computer for next to nothing that in the
1960s would have cost over a million
dollars I don't see why they owe more in
taxes than I do just because they're
worth many more billions than I am well
let's explore that though so question
one you don't have to tell me how much
money you make but if we were to talk
about if if we're to talk about
quintiles right dividing into five
quintiles the the people's people's
income are you aware that the average
effective tax rate that people are
paying is essentially identical from the
60th percentile on up did you know that
I've heard that argument that in fact
you're saying in terms of a percentage
that people pay of their income to the
government exactly so in spite of the
fact that we have a sort of ostensibly
progressive tax code where the more you
make the more you pay as a percentage of
your income once you get to the 60th
percentile taking into consideration all
taxes that are paid you the average is
about 32 percent from 60 percentile on
up well it's an interesting argument and
I would say what that you what you're
telling me is the government's taking
way too much of everyone's income
certainly what what we're leaving out of
this is let's face it it's the top one
percent of earners and I'm not one of
them who've foot the bill for the vast
majority of government and I
think that's a good idea and I would add
I think it's a terrible idea if we're
trying to lift the income and growth
possibilities of those not in the 1% ok
so then now that's really getting into
the meat of what I want to discuss in
your op-ed you say senators Rubio and
Lee have feebly called for a reduction
in the top tax rate from thirty nine
point six percent to 35 percent
lest we forget there are no companies
and no jobs without investment first the
rich by definition have the most
disposable income to invest as as a
liberal self-proclaimed libertarian I
would imagine you would realize that
business investment is tax deductible
and a higher rate on personal income
would actually encourage business
investment and I'll give an example and
of course I'll allow you to either agree
or disagree with me
if I'm if I'm 1% guy right and my top
tax if my top marginal tax rate is
thirty nine point six percent instead of
thirty five percent or thirty percent or
twenty five percent I would want to
invest that in a business because that
expenditure is tax deductible and I'm
saving thirty-nine percent instead of
the lower 35 or 30 or 25 percent a
higher top marginal tax rate encourages
investment I'm not buying this argument
simply because unless correct me if I'm
wrong
yeah little gains rate on investment if
you actually get a return is 20 percent
and so tax deductible or not I don't
again what you're you seem to be
encouraging or is the tax code being
used to encourage investment or not I
don't want either I want the government
not having a role or a decision and
whether money is invested or not and
what I would say is if we allow the rich
to hold on to their wealth whether they
love business or not odds are it's going
to find its way to new business but
that's empirically untrue that's been
widely debunked if you have any data
that suggests that the rich don't have a
drastically higher marginal propensity
to save than the poor I would love to
see it there is not one legitimate study
that suggests that and a simple thought
experiment I think we'll hold on a
second bow hold on let me get let me get
the question out and then you can take
it whatever direction you want the
richer you are the less likely you are
to need that additional money and it's
been widely shown that the richer you
are the higher percentage of new income
you are to save rather than invest and
lowering the top tax rate only
encourages that activity oh well you
thank you very much for saying that
because you just made my point
beautifully you've made the argument
that I make to people all the time so
let's say let's say I'm one of those
much demonized one percenters and I'm
worth billions and I'm mr. Scrooge okay
so maybe I'm kind of conservative with
my money so I'm going to keep it all in
the bank or cash equivalent if I do our
banks paying me interest on on my wealth
because they want to stare it lovingly
no they're lending it out to those who
have immediate consumptive needs they
want to buy a car they want to buy a
house they need to ition money for their
kids or better yet maybe they want that
maybe they want a loan so they can start
a business if I am holding on to my well
it is by definition being redistributed
to people not nearly as wealthy as I am
there's a couple problems with that
argument number one is that while you're
not wrong that the money that a one
percenter save socks away is going to be
then turned into loans which banks make
when we look at the economic multiplier
of spending a dollar here versus a
dollar there versus a dollar there we
know that money sent through the banking
system the way you describe has one of
the smallest economic multipliers in
some cases in fact with some hedge fund
and equity equity fund activity the way
you're describing it has a negative
multiplier effect so while what you're
saying is not inaccurate every serious
economic study shows that if a rich
person actually spends or invests that
money in real business this
effect is orders of magnitude greater
than saying I'll save it and banks will
lend that money and all you're really
doing when you do that is just enriching
banks by allowing them to collect
interest okay great and look and I'll be
the first to tell you I'm not against
banks but I thought it was a very big
mistake that we bailed out the banks but
again you're making my point for me I
don't think I am constantly hear about
how the rich are really greedy in
everything I've not said that let's
focus on what you and I have said
generally what what what would I often
hear okay so you're right most be having
worked in in private wealth I know this
intimately they generally don't want to
keep it in cash or cash equivalents all
I'm saying and bringing up the banks is
that if they do that yeah their wealth
is by definition being lent out to
others in many instances not nearly as
wealthy as they are to to say otherwise
to say that banks sit on money is to
just is to is to engage in falsehood but
who has said that because my argument my
argument doesn't include the assertion
that banks sit on money I can say that
most don't want to do that in fact they
want to invest in the stock market in
which case we're getting a better
multiple that are investing in more
innovative companies but even more than
that has many of them want to invest in
venture capital funds the problem is
that if even though you may know people
that want to do that there are broad
economic analyses that tell us that the
marginal propensity to save for a for a
one-percenter is so much higher than for
someone who is lower on the income
brackets and that's the stimulative
effect of putting that money in the
hands of those with a higher marginal
propensity to spend is orders of
magnitude higher than just stocking that
money away in stocks so while you're not
wrong how is it that we're having this
conversation are we having it on skype
yes it is yeah well begin how did Scott
with Skype created did you just come out
of thin air or is it a result of savings
nobody is arguing that that all savings
is bad the issue is when we're talking
about tax policy as a point LC so you
you would
prefer do you think it's more
stimulative for the government to take
more of the wealth held by the
one-percenters and what would you do
that
who would redistribute this wealth it's
not an issue of redistributing the
wealth it's an issue of hold on a second
hold on a second hon Oh hon you're
making a bunch of different disjointed
arguments all based on quality
supply-side nonsense you think what you
think what I think is based on the facts
and the fact is hold on a second whoa
whoa whoa hold on you asked me a
question and you asked me a question and
you're not letting the answer okay your
argument is that to stimulate investment
you may this is in black and white it's
in the town hall article that to
stimulate investment the top tax rate
should drop not from thirty nine point
six percent to 35 percent as senator
Rubio has suggested but it should drop
much more to stimulate investment that's
what you said in the article can we at
least agree on that
absolutely okay what I'm saying is that
it has been demonstrated beyond reproach
that to create an incentive for
investment there needs to be if I cannot
pay 39 percent by investing my money or
I can pet not pay 30 percent by
investing my money not paying 39 percent
is a much more compelling reason to
invest than not paying 30 percent I mean
how could you deny that it's just simple
math how can I deny it your breed you
keep bringing up demonstrated beyond
poor approach in studies but of course
you can't produce and I can't I can't
have access to them right now but let's
forget forget let's just talk as two
reasonable people hold on hold on let me
reframe it you're making a fair point
yet beyond
there are no companies and no jobs
without investment first I would rather
leave the wealth created in society in
the private sector let's just do a
simple thing let hold on a second John
let's Reese let's refocus let me just
ask you a question you have $100 right I
say to you listen if you keep that
hundred dollars at the end of the year
I'm gonna take 40% of it okay or I say
if you keep that hundred dollars at the
end of the year I'm gonna take 5% of it
the way to avoid me taking either amount
is by investing the money in a business
are you going to be more likely to
invest to avoid losing the $40 or the $5
I it's entirely possible that I would be
more likely not to invest because I
don't know about you but I've worked a
lot in the investment industry most
investments fail nice job the idea that
that you that an investment is a one-way
street
is kind of fanciful it's not a world
that I'm familiar with but then you're
making a different argument now now
you're saying actually the government
shouldn't incentivize investment because
it's risky but what does the government
do right now if I buy a new york city or
a california municipal bond to fund
government spending I don't pay any tax
on the income at all federal or City but
if I have the temerity to take my wealth
and invest in a future Google or
Microsoft well if I get income on that
investment I'm gonna pay a tax on that
but it's a far smaller tax bill than
paying it is income right you admit that
yeah you're absolutely right and I think
that's unfortunate I hope not like the
idea that government taxes income at
such a high rate in my perfect in my
perfect world they would cap tax capital
gains at zero I don't see why we would
tax those who are providing capital to
the businesses and jobs of the future it
is a mystery to me all right well that
is certainly a different conversation
which we can have we've been speaking
with John Tammany the book of course is
popular economics with the Rolling
Stones Downton Abbey and LeBron James
can teach you about economics released
today I hope there's some demand side
economics in that book otherwise it's
going to be it's gonna be a tough one to
get through John but I appreciate you
being on and even even though we didn't
agree on much it's an interesting
conversation thank you thank you